one de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
merci
la parole est à monsieur eric woerth
monsieur le premier ministre le porte
parole du gouvernement monsieur le foll
a déclaré ce matin ce n'est pas vrai la
france n'a pas décroché visiblement
votre ministre de l'agriculture s'est
spécialisée dans l'élevage d'autruches
vous refuser de regarder la vérité en
face en mettant à tête dans le sable
votre gouvernement incarne la france de
l'indécision
oui monsieur le premier ministre la
france décroche et décline c'est une
réalité le chômage de masse perdure la
dette continue de progresser les 100%
pipe seront atteints les déficits
publics se réduit à la vitesse de
l'escargot et les dépenses publiques
repartent à la hausse jamais nos
agriculteurs ne se sont sentis autant
abandonner la france est aujourd'hui à
la merci d'une europe fragilisée par les
crises migratoires et par lebrac si
votre gouvernement n'a pas su repenser
le modèle social et économique pour
mieux le protéger et si les déficits de
la sécurité sociale vont mieux c'est
parce que nous avons procédé notamment à
l'indispensable réforme des retraites
ouvrez les yeux nous avons perdu cinq
ans la france subit de plein fouet une
crise sociale et identitaire très forte
à laquelle vous jugé bon d'ajouter une
crise institutionnelle qui fait de la
france la risée de l'europe est ce bien
le moment d'instaurer cette pitoyable
compétition entre un premier ministre et
un président de la république en
exercice la primaire de la gauche ne
doit pas l'emporter sur les services de
la france seul un diagnostic réaliste et
un langage de vérité permettront à la
france de se réformer vous dites qu'il
est impossible de faire 100 milliards
d'économies qu'il est impossible de
réduire le nombre d'agents publics qu'il
est impossible d'augmenter l'âge de la
retraite vous nous faites un procès en
sorcellerie sur la protection sociale
sur la sécurité sociale alors que ce
sont vos décisions qui conduisent les
salariés être moins bien remboursé
qu'avant vous militez pour une france
faible alors que nous voulons une france
forte alors monsieur le premier ministre
kan porterez-vous un regard lucide sur
la france quand comprendrez-vous la
colère et le désarroi des français
quelle est votre feuille de route
précise pour les cinq ans pour les cinq
mois par dont les cinq derniers mois
merkel
la parole est à monsieur michel sapin
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le président
monsieur le député monsieur le ministre
sans considérer que le lapsus de faim
était révélateur de quelque chose le
souhait de voir cette majorité ce
gouvernement continuer son action parce
que la france évidemment on n'est pas en
situation de décrochage la france elle
se redresse elle se redresse et si vous
le disiez ainsi trop lentement ou pas
assez vite par rapport à ce que vous
souhaiteriez peut-être pourrais-je
acceptée mais la manière dont vous
décrivez les choses on donnerait le
sentiment que depuis 2012 date à
laquelle me semble-t-il monsieur le
ministre vous aviez quelques
responsabilités quant à la gestion de la
france de son budget de son déficit de
là haut de sa dette de sa dépendance de
plus en plus grandissante vis-à-vis des
marchés les internationaux auxquels vous
adresser pour nous prêter de l'argent à
d'ailleurs des prix très cher beaucoup
plus cher qu'aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre si vous placiez avec rigueur
avec cette rigueur qu'on peut vous
connaître par ailleurs si vous placiez
avec rigueur dans la comparaison entre
l'état de la france telle que vous
l'avez laissée et là tu as de la france
aujourd'hui vous ne diriez pas que la
france a décroché parce que la france
elle s'est redressée elle a fait des
efforts les français ont fait des
efforts parfois vous pouvez en
bénéficier
parce que des efforts peuvent créer
aussi des incertitudes des inquiétudes
ou des douleurs mais la france a fait
les efforts et ces efforts là que vous
ne voulez pas reconnaître et c'est ce
que je vous reprocherai le plus c'est
une forme d' injure faite aux français
que de dire que la france continue à
décliner alors que la france aujourd'hui
se redresse c'est une injure faite aux
entreprises françaises que de laisser
penser qu'elles sont aujourd'hui dans un
état pire que celui que vous avez laissé
alors que vous savez très bien que les
entreprises françaises ont retrouvé
leurs marges qui étaient les marges de
2007 et qu'elles ont retrouvé des
investissements qui étaient même ce que
d'avant vous même vous aviez pu créer
voilà la raison pour laquelle monsieur
le ministre oui un débat est nécessaire
oui le débat démocratique c'est le
comprend la mer sont bien sûr